هذا هو كيكر ، إنه
نظام ترفيهي متعدد الإمكانات قائم على نظام Android من شركة
keikar وهي شركة فرنسية ناشئة في الأساس عبارة عن
تقاطع بين جهاز عرض Alexa
وروبوت يقوم بتشغيل الأفلام الموسيقية والبرامج التلفزيونية ،
ومن المفترض أن يعمل
مكبر الصوت ، انتقل إلى مشروع غرفة النوم keager
على السقف ولكنه ليس سلسًا مثل
خرائط keikar المعلن عنها لمنزلك ، لذلك
عند الاتصال به في الغرفة ، يمكنه
اكتشاف أفضل طريقة للوصول إلى هناك ، ولكن لا
يزال من الممكن أن يضيع ويتوقف إذا
تعثر ، يمكنك دائمًا تحريكه  إلى المكان
الذي تريده ولكنه نظام صعب ،
فهو يحتوي على ميزة كاميرا
رائعة تعمل مثل نظام الأمان
وجودة جهاز العرض جيدة جدًا ولكن
هذا لا يعني أن جميع جدران
منزلك هي أماكن رائعة لمشاهدة
التلفزيون
بشكل عام  يعد keikar بأكثر مما يمكن تسليمه
بالفعل
وبسعر باهظ ، حتى أكثر المتحمسين للروبوتات صبرًا
قد يواجهون صعوبة في
سعال المال